hey i'm dave rubin welcome to the rubin
report I've got Aaron Foley with me I've
got Howard Bragman and you know when we
started doing this show I wanted to sort
of bring the lighter side of politics of
current events and mix it up with
comedians personalities interesting
people and hopefully get a slightly
different take on everything going on
unfortunately earlier today there was
the terror attack at the Boston Marathon
and I would be remiss if we did a whole
week's show and didn't talk about it so
I wanted to just get to it a little bit
and we're not going to delve that deep
because it's still obviously unfolding
there's going to be a lot of stuff
that'll come out in the next month the
next couple weeks but I felt we had to
talk about it a little bit so let's
start with this do you guys think it was
just a matter of time before there was
going to be another attack I mean it was
actually if you jump back to 911 the
last thing we've had on American soil
was you know 12 years ago that's a long
time so is this just a time thing what
do you think well yeah I definitely I
mean I lived in New York during the
whole 911 and I just remember those
months after it thinking you know then
it was the anthrax and it just like it
didn't stop and I just remember like
week after week being like well we ever
get like a normal week again you know
like you take everything for granted and
and then I was just I mean not to be
morbid I was just absolutely shocked
that we haven't had something maybe not
on that scale but you know you just
every week you'd hear like oh they can
get into the subway they can you know
it's cybertek you know so I think you
know thankfully hasn't happened you know
hasn't happened before this but it's
just it takes you right back to
September 11th and you know friends
family and it's just my sister's a
marathon runner it's just it's so like
it just makes you absolutely stomach
sick it's just just horrifying but you
know it is in a way to think that's you
know the first big thing this happens
this 911 is thankfully surprising yeah
what do you think do you think it was
just a matter of time before something I
mean things have happened international
yes the world we live in okay
if you been to the Middle East you been
to Israel been to a lot of European
countries you don't go to grocery store
without getting a you know mag down and
check for weapons yeah and and we've
been pretty immune in the u.s. I mean we
have lots of crazy people with guns who
will take you out movie theaters but
which feels terrorists to me yeah white
frankly but you know well that would get
into the whole definition of terror
already we know is going to be coming
over the next couple weeks well if this
was you know it seems it was some sort
of quote-unquote homemade bomb or you
know something you could have found on
the internet but you know people were
terrorized and people are dead and and
you know 150 or give or take her injured
it yeah at this point three dead that's
terror yeah and and that's the world we
have to live in and I think what we have
to understand is there are so many
targets of opportunity we talked about
the Oscars and the Academy Awards here
and we say well we have to protect that
you can't protect everything with 25,000
runners how do you stop you go into
everybody's knapsack you make every you
just can't do it anymore right and how
much Liberty do we want to give up for
freedom because do we want to be having
people you know security guards go
through our bags as we enter the mall
and that whole thing what do you guys
think about just the way information is
changed since nine eleven I mean just
being on Twitter today which I was
completely glued to the way we're so
intimately involved where you can see
pictures on the fly and read tweets from
people that are there so you feel very
connected and then in another way it
shows you how how far we are away from
people because there's this very
personal thing happening and and you're
part of it but you're not part of its
wild if we had had some of that stuff
ten years ago 11 years yeah I remember
just trying to get to a landline to call
my mother you know and try to figure out
where both my sisters were in New York
City we're all in New York City trying
to figure out all right I think she's on
60th Street my older sisters in Brooklyn
maybe that's its you're just you had no
idea you didn't even know what part of
the city you could cross you know but
with today I don't know for me it's a
wonderful thing because you're getting I
mean you know it's horrible cuz you're
seeing all this but you do feel like
okay
you the more knowledge in like a crisis
situation the better even basically
you're seeing on Twitter day it's like
Boston police saying don't go in this
area go like you know and just tracking
victims and tracking loved ones uh so I
think that's it's pretty amazing what
you can do now social media do you think
the social media can actually sort of
spread the fear you know years ago
before television or radio if something
happened in one part of the world people
didn't find out about it till you know a
ship got across an ocean I know it's
like this constantly I think the most
interesting part is we get a different
perspective but we're used to Fox and
MSNBC and CNN you know and that's that's
the business new or excuse me the news
perspective that we've gotten yeah now
you get different people and in it you
get a lot of innuendo you get a lot of
rumor you get a lot of stuff that turns
out not to be true but I guess the good
news is you get a lot of stuff first and
foremost in you and you get to hear it
it's just going through it and knowing
how much credence to give a certain
thing and and how much not it's you know
people always go is Twitter good as
Facebook good is it bad it's just a fact
of life it just is all right well
obviously this stuff is going to keep
you know there's gonna be the big story
for the next couple months but so just
one other one other thing on this how
quickly do you think it's going to be
before the blame game starts kicking in
whether it's that we're blaming the FBI
or the CIA you know we still don't even
know buddy's claimed responsibility
again we're doing this monday night just
few hours after this this attack
occurred but how quickly before we just
get into that unpredictable okay i mean
even with 911 arguably there were
certain warnings this was pretty
nobody's taking credit for this there
was no as we know intelligence buzz on
this i mean it is so this feels a little
different it feels almost like it did in
Atlanta when the bomb went off during
the Olympics that are a little more
grown for sure yeah I mean when you go
back and I'm sure the Intel will come
out and maybe of course they'll be a
blame game and be like why didn't you
pick up this wine you pick up that but
the alarm you think about 911 was there
were so many signs I mean when you're
when you're dealing with an airline like
a carer a pilot Academy that people
don't want to learn how to lay on the
plane right you don't mean you're like
oh hey hey you know what i mean so
because it was so alarming when that
evidence came out that you were like how
could you know yeah but now we're on a
different level where you know you and
condi rice not close yes I had to take
her off from a Facebook page yeah um but
yeah it just so this obviously stuff
will come out and everyone you know get
blame but I think honestly you have to
say like in the last 10 12 years it
seems like you there's been so many good
of so many you know times where you're
like all right well that intelligence
came in that would stop that get wrong
ones you're seeing yes it either our
intelligence is a lot better and it
saved us a bunch of times or maybe it's
not as good as we think it is but either
way we'll keep talking about this
there's gonna be plenty more on it and
all right now let's get back to the
funny stuff bonobos calm is the official
outfitter of the Ruben report I want to
put you in this slim fit shirt go to
bonobos calm enter code trr 20 for
twenty percent off your next purchase